trekkies rejoice season one of star trek
discovery is continuing to air
right here on eight news now with
seasons two and three available
over on cbs all access in honor of the
epic space battles orco mana introduces
us to a local star trek super fan
who has found more than just a franchise
to love
my interest in star trek started back in
the late 70s
take a look around paul walker's
henderson apartment posters the plates
the cups the steins and you'll quickly
realize his love for the space epic star
trek is out of this world did i mention
i have them all on dvd
79 episodes for decades paul's been
collecting memorabilia
and signed souvenirs he even has an
actual classic costume
from the original series he founded the
local star trek fan club known as the
uss las vegas nearly 16 years ago
they hold movie and television premiere
events as well as monthly meetings paul
says it's not just the space battles
that make star trek so special
it's the idea that we work together to
solve problems
we don't have the problems in the 23rd
21st century that we're seeing today
to explore strange new worlds paul also
worked at star trek the experience and
interactive
fan paradise located in las vegas
although it closed in 2008 he still has
pieces of its past including a menu from
quarks restaurant
you ordered a flaming ribs of targ which
is basically barbecue spare ribs
and his most prized possession this
admiral sign
what thing can a star trek club have
over the years through his
decades-long passion for star trek paul
hasn't only found these collectibles
he also found love cupid's arrow
he shot he struck it is never boring
paul met his domestic partner robert
when they both worked at star trek the
experience their mutual love of the
franchise turning into a deep connection
with each other
i wasn't looking for anything but i
found it
and it's you know it's been a good thing
for 15 years now as the years have gone
by
paul and robert have not slowed down
whether it's the original show
with such little data i'd prefer not to
speculate
or the brand new episodes of star trek
discovery they're still super fans
through and through
kovid 19 has kept their fan club
meetings virtual for now
but they know no matter what their
enthusiasm will live long
and prosper there is never a bad time to
be a star trek fan
orco mana 8 news now